we've got a lot to talk about today
though my first of course would like to
talk about our season four premiere
which is going to be a tribute to both
Luke Perry and Fred Andros Roberto when
you and the writers were approaching
this episode to begin with what was your
role in this episode and bringing Luke's
legacy to life I think it was exactly
that you know we we when Luke passed was
towards the end of season 3 and we
thought that rather than rush an episode
in or a storyline in that we would take
our time and the first two weeks that we
met as as the writers we we just talked
about this episode and that's exactly
what you said we really wanted to honor
Luke we really wanted to honor Fred and
we wanted it to be sort of a very
special episode kind of standalone and
it really emotional and really focused
on what this character meant to this
group of people his son his friends and
and and really the entire town of
Revenue now I understand there were a
lot of special elements that you wanted
to include in this episode a lot of
special people and you make a special
announcement yeah
one of when we were putting it together
we wanted to be episode as you said to
be as special as possible and one of the
things that Luke had talked about since
season 1 is he really wanted his good
friend Shannen Doherty to come on to
and we tried to make it happen a few
times didn't work out but when we were
putting together this episode we really
wanted to include her Alistair shannen
doherty is in in 401 and a really
[Applause]
she's able to share a lot of scenes with
all of our cast members what was it like
welcoming Shannon to the Riverdale cast
I mean I think it was cathartic for all
of us I think it really put the cherry
on top of that episode and really made a
nice tribute and she was overjoyed to to
have the ability to to share some of the
burden of Luke's passing that she had
gone through in a sort of cathartic
setting with the rest of us and it was
it was beautiful and it was touching and
she's so talented and was also so close
to Luke and it seemed like it seemed
like a perfect fit for us Roberto can be
seen the lovely Molly Ringwald just make
more of an appearance this year as Berry
interest yeah we definitely will you
know it so happened that meri was
actually Mary that Holly was in
Vancouver shooting an episode around
when when when Luke passed and I saw her
and she said you know please don't
introduce Archie's uncle please I'd love
to help out I'd love to be more a part
of this and we wanted the same thing so
yes she'll be she'll be she'll be tea
parties mom more or less full time this
season which are
[Applause]
for more episodes this year it's great I
think it's gonna be a nice benefit we've
been really going to dive into their
relationship too much so yeah it's going
to be you have to talk about of course
the biggest cliffhanger that we saw at
the end of the season 3 finale which was
that Betty Archie and Veronica were in a
flash Florida Spring Break they were in
the middle that was wearing not too much
and covered in blood and the only thing
we saw of Jughead was his iconic beanie
when you first read that script what was
your reaction no more smelly hat now I
like it i mean i think i think the
beanie and and the whoopee cap has
served as kind of the most iconic symbol
for the Archie comics for for 75 years
aside from from KJ's rooster top and I
think I think the act of burning it is
is a really good hook I think it's
really interesting but I'm not gonna
spoil anything which is why you guys are
even listening right now
Lilly KJ and cami was like for you to
film that scene cold recently it was
like 3:00 in the morning and we were
naked and we had no idea what I just
happened
so we're just like you know just stare
into the fire like okay just look
serious
Roberta are you gonna make us wait I'll
season before we get those answers I
don't know you we um this season that's
one of our big big mysteries obviously
what happened to chuck him and the kids
that night and we are building up it
they're kind of the middle of the season
our mid-season finale is going to be the
that night depicted in the flash board
and in episodes leading up to it we're
gonna flash forward to other events from
that night and immediately after that
night so you'll start to kind of piece
it together I think I'm also really
excited because we're getting a
Halloween episode this year was the so
exciting from a Sheryl blossom
well it's our favorite time of the year
naturally has we got the heroin that she
is so it's going to be a very fun
episode that we're it's it's a the
support we've never been able to do a
Halloween episode because the schedule
has never worked out so this year
episode floor airs on October 30th so
we've got a really fun spooky episode
for everyone it was someone 9 yes
important no no no no one at the station
Roberto have you already figured out
what our characters will be dressing up
for it for Halloween did you know it's
so funny week I know what is going to be
depended dressed as and we're trying to
get clearance on some DC comic book
characters for Sheryl and Tony is at
home giving out candy to
trick-or-treaters so scary story so I'm
the one who dies
let's keep the conversation going with
focusing on Betty
you know Betty and Jughead have always
have a lot in common like their shared
love of sleuthing and the ability to
look amazing and leather jackets but now
they also have a shared half-brother as
we were introduced to Charles in the
season 3 finale how does the
introduction of their real half-brother
can I kind of shake up their dynamic
this dear Lily I don't know I mean I
think I think there might be some
awkward family dinners in the future but
I also think maybe it's a good
opportunity if you know once if and when
Alice returns her farm for maybe Alice
and fp2 rekindle something but I think I
don't know they're not related by blood
so I guess it's fine right
there are categories for that on the
Internet
Jughead is once again introducing
audiences to a new school in Riverdale
yeah what can you tell us about his
academic journey in season four I think
I think is well this is a prep school so
Jughead gets whisked away on a
scholarship to a very sort of gossip
girl Upper East Side preppy pretentious
Richie Rich silver spoon Richie Rich is
the character everybody's here
and he's going to be the new blood and
he's part of this writing scholarship so
so he's part of this little Dead Poets
Society that they have overhead and at
this new school and junkets already kind
of a pretentious character so he's going
to be not pretentious by all of the
incredibly tall and beautiful people but
yeah I think it's fun and the school
also kind of serves I'd assume maybe I'm
just speaking on a turn here but it
serves as the setting for what the
flash-forward yeah some of the one of
the big mysteries of the season is kind
of centered around
Jughead at the at the new school which
is also kind of going to be a big rival
school for Riverdale high so Archie and
the Bulldogs will be having a football
match with the Stonewall statics which
is what statics like a dear I understand
we're gonna be seeing a lot more of our
sibling dynamics this year and seeing a
lot more scenes between Jughead and
jellybean which I'm really excited about
Cole what are you hoping to see from
their sibling dynamic moving forward I
really like the
in the comics were jug and it is so
overprotective of jellybean which I
which I thought was kind of cute in the
digest but it's also kind of it's kind
of a weird thing for an older brother to
do so I'd like to see I'd like to see
how Trinity works with feeling maybe a
bit uncomfortable with that I like older
protective job quite a bit no it's gonna
be bro
no one's scared of you both of the
parents are in jail right now so what
does that mean for Veronica's home life
I mean there's nobody home but she could
invite whoever she wants a length length
are you gonna be shooting any scenes
with it I think there's a lot of scenes
to shoot up in Brooklyn but Kim Anderson
you're also gonna be having some
extended family dropping him there in
there is an extended family member in
Marana cos life that she didn't know
existed which is definitely going to be
another part of ronica storyline in
season four anything else you can tease
for us I don't think so okay obviously
Archie's gonna be wrestling a lot this
year
brush the wrestling with a lot this year
but I am saying probably realize
well he does every single sport out
there at this point probably still
boxing but he's going to be dealing with
the death of his father but what else
can you tell us about his journey in
season four yeah it's gonna be a lot of
football this season which is gonna be
fun I love working with Charles doing
all that just melts into place Reggie
it'll be nice the advantage that
[Music]
actually is we're finding out his real
name which is something I just you know
I know you guys are related to no I
don't need the name and he could
possibly be being introduced into the
Bulldogs which which could be fun yeah
and you can't talk about football and
Archie without mentioning music so what
can you choose who the fans that's
coming up before signing a band called
they are GZ Roberto why did you want to
bring this iconic Archie's comic fans to
life the season you know you know it's
funny when originally we when I
originally pitched the TV series in my
mind the end of season 1 was going to be
a big battle of advance between the
Archies and the Pussycats and of course
the show then became what it became and
as we were getting ready to do a bunch
of stories in the high school cuz its
senior year I was like it this year or
Never
so we're doing a battle of bands
which I think will be really really fun
are you saying break that it's just ours
Roberta yeah well the in the in the
cartoon arches guitar and lead singer
Veronica's tambourine tambourine I think
she's the timbre check it is on drums
and then brought a keyboard maybe sex
appeal yeah we'll figure it out sex is
like
call I think I speak for all of us when
I say you blew everyone away on the song
17 and
so is Jughead singing gonna be a more
regular occurrence
I don't know Roberto is it German
cappella band
I do love every time we get to hear
madelung things she has such an amazing
voice will we be here hearing her more
this year yeah definitely we'll still be
doing or we're definitely gonna do a
musical episode the way we did in season
two and three and we'll have songs kind
of throughout the season as we normally
do
thanks Liam that's all I know
Marilla must be of course talked about
some relationships so we're gonna go
through some of our favorite couples
right now and our cast members you could
tell us what you know is coming up for
them and then also what you think their
ideal date would be so kicking us off
Madeline what can you tell us about
Sheryl and Tony even season four
I love them together we come up and
season four starting with them in a
fairly strong place like they're
starting off well obviously Cheryl is
keeping a body science secret from her
girlfriends so I think we'll probably
get into this stickiness of that in a
little bit but I nominate to the hope
and believe that the show DHN game I
think they're so sweet together and to
me that's not such a great sign of
Cheryl so we'll see I guess this would
be going on the motorcycle and just you
know going on the block saying that home
watches movie animal anything cute oh
very cute
Lillian : you tell us about Betty and
Jughead we are you know Jughead is going
to prep her school so he's only going to
be in Riverdale on the weekends so I
don't know I mean I think there Betty is
really supportive of him and she thinks
he's such a good writer and and fully
supported him going to this school
because she wants the best for him and
for his education you know he wants to
be the first Jones man to go to college
so she's super supportive event
as far as their relationship I think I
think they're strong but I'm sure
something's gonna have
yeah I mean then as of now they're super
strong but I'm sure the prep school in
there I'm sure there's going to be you
know a little bit offbeat outsider Manic
Pixie dream girl inside of the prep
school be this jacket no idea but yeah
they're super strong right now and I
think the distance can make the heart
grow solve it in like half a second hey
Jamie what can you tell us about the
runt and Archie this year he's killing
her right now I think with both of them
going through stuff this season I think
it's good they have each other means a
lot to Buffalo yeah I think especially
with everything that's going on in
Archie's personal life
we saw Veronica but last time when
something tragic happened she didn't
know what to do is you know how to be a
girlfriend for him and then this time we
see her really stepping up to the plate
and being there being supportive being
strong for him and it's made them
stronger and their ideal date very deal
day and now like a shower under this
Jeff
[Music]
another fireside rendezvous murder fans
have been asking for years about Tony
topaz's backstory if this year we're
gonna get it we are definitely getting
her backstory I will say that we do know
some stuff about about Tony's we know we
met her grandfather once we know that
her uncle wasn't supportive when when
Tony tried to come out so we are
definitely going to learn a little bit
more about that at work and I think
we're good if we are to see Tony in a
good place and and we've got some fun
stuff planned for instance on Halloween
for them like what do a disability
[Music]
for sure
[Music]